en pratique on s'aperçoit être
quelquefois la discussion elle est très
limité mots quand on m'appelle le
vendredi soir on appelle encore une fois
par politesse mais pas pour me demander
mon avis on me dit demain arriveront à
12h30 15 migrants sur votre territoire
points merci monsieur le maire or voit
[Musique]
habituellement dans ce type d'événement
on sait qu'elle est la physionomie des
arrivants là on savait pas de quelle
nationalité il était si il était
exactement 15 ou moins ou plus on savait
simplement que le lendemain matin allait
être démantelé un peu dans l'urgence de
manière très rapide jaillir même un peu
brutal un campement et que on nous
amènerait chez nous à châteauroux une
partie de ces migrants la corée pas
voulu pas demandez peut-être même pas su
qu'ils allaient venir chez cas
rapidement dans les 48 heures qui ont
suivi dix sont repartis sur paris bonne
partie d'entre eux avaient un travail il
devait retourner à paris travaille et il
n'avait pas demandé à venir en province
il a été un peu surpris du fait qu'on
l'ait monde dans des bus pour les a
menés 48 heures après n'avait plus que
cinq ces cinq là sont encore aujourd'hui
sur notre territoire deux afghans et
deux somaliens et un malien
[Musique]
il est clairement un problème de méthode
habituellement quand un camp et
démantelé il ya quand même un travail
qui est fait les jours précédents pour
aller à la rencontre de celles et ceux
qui sont là pour leur demander quelle
est leur situation et essayer de trouver
une solution plus ou moins adapté ce
démantèlement là il a été fait dans la
précipitation dans la non préparation et
le vendredi soir pour le samedi matin
c'est pas une manière on va dire normal
de travailler pour des services d'état
et les services des collectivités
locales que nous sommes là on a bien vu
qu'il y avait une volonté d'agir vite de
montrer que l'état était là et que force
devait rester à la loi mais on ne peut
pas traiter des humains de manière
technocratique
[Musique]
c'est pas qu'on veut pas on a déjà un
centre d'accueil qui est complet
aujourd'hui qui compte plus de 150
places en 69 exactement on a des
associations qui travaillent justement à
côté de ces migrants pour les intérêts
quand on a un accueil des nouveaux il
faut qu'on ait des places de libres déjà
pour les loger convenablement là en
l'occurrence ils n'ont pas été l'objet
dans le centre d'accueil ils ont été
logés dans un hôtel ce qui oblige les
services sociaux à se déplacer on les
attendait pas eu son arrivée en france
en vont vouloir forcément venir chez
nous donc c'est du cas par cas on peut
pas traiter des humains comme un colis
condé placerait et comporterait auprès
d'une clientèle sur le territoire
national
[Musique]
la répartition je pense que c'est une
fausse bonne idée on peut se dire
qu'effectivement sur le territoire il ya
des zones rurales c'est le cas du
département de l'indre qui perdent des
habitants et qu'on pourrait re peuple et
ses départements là en y mettant des
migrants des gens qui sont arrivés dans
notre pays la réalité des fêtes elle est
différente c'est à dire que ces migrants
souvent la france est pas leur payer
destination ils veulent aller en
angleterre ils veulent passer par calais
puis rejoindre londres où les
différentes villes anglaises qui
pourront leur donner un avenir
professionnel qui veulent aussi avant
tout c'est une situation meilleure que
celle qu'ils ont quittée dans leur pays
donc c'est leur trouver de l'emploi
s'est pas forcément toujours sur nos
territoires où ils vont trouver les
meilleurs postes où les plus adaptées à
leur formation ou les dispositifs
d'accompagnement d'intégration les plus
performants la délocalisation réduire ou
la relocalisation sur le territoire ça
peut fonctionner pour une petite partie
de ces migrants mais ça peut pas être
une solution généralisée
[Musique]
à châteauroux comme ailleurs on a une
population issue de l'immigration giraud
lendemain de la seconde guerre car
arrivés d'afrique d'algérie de tunisie
du maroc cela aujourd'hui sont intégrés
certains encore pas totalement mais
quand même globalement de manière
satisfaisante n'a depuis quelques mois
quelques années des nouvelles migrations
qui viennent
des comores notamment de mayotte et des
alentours on a aussi une population
africaine subsaharienne qui arrive avec
une autre culture d'autres modes de vie
qui s'installe dans nos quartiers
populaires on a les autres populations
historique dont je parlais à l'instant
il faut réussir à faire cohabiter les
uns les autres certains étant installé
là depuis longtemps et est donc ayant
leurs habitudes et d'autres venant avec
des pratiques très différentes le fait
de ramener immédiatement sur nos
territoires des populations nouvelles
encore différente alors qu'on n'a pas
fini d'intégrer les précédentes ça c'est
problématique et ses sources de tension
notamment dans les quartiers populaires
tire là on a des logements de disponible
et là où ces populations pauvres 1 pour
l'essentiel parce qu'elles n'ont pas de
revenus ma peine à s'intégrer
[Musique]
effectivement la politique migratoire
elle est mal maîtrisée mais qu'elle est
difficilement maîtrisable c'est à dire
que les entrées on peut pas accuser le
gouvernement de laisser rentrer à
tout-va l'immigration sur le territoire
on sait qu'elle se fait de manière
illégale et assume ses responsabilités
dans le sens où il gère le dire le
problème liger le déplacement de
populations de migrants l'espèce il
prend en charge financièrement la
dépense simplement il la mène sur un
territoire mais ce territoire on est
dans un pays décentralisé il est quand
même gérer par des élus et l'état peut
pas transposer des populations de l'île
de france en province sans à socialiser
malgré la décentralisation malgré les
discours qui disent on est attaché aux
élus on s'appuie on respecte les met en
pratique on s'aperçoit de quelques fois
la discussion elle est très limité mais
quand on m'appelle le vendredi soir on
appelle encore une fois par politesse
mais pas pour me demander mon avis on
dit demain arriveront à 12h30 15
migrants sur votre territoire points
merci monsieur le maire au revoir on est
mis sur le fait accompli à l'instant t
alors qu'on sait très bien qu'on aura
besoin de nous de la suite
[Musique]